got to be tough
plus women constantly judged by your
looks that's got to be exhausting
constantly judged by your look but you
all know how to look good you all look
great that's how women figured out to
take the selfie up here that was all you
ladies you know what your good sight
lines are i think that's why women like
tall guys just some guy looking at you
from your best angle 100 of the time all
day long that's why you don't hook up
with short guys just some guy like jeez
look at the triple chin on this broad oh
yeah
yeah you like a tall man ladies and
that's okay that's how you're wired
you're all a bunch of height
supremacists
that was always the first question back
on the dating apps you over six feet you
over six feet over six feet i felt bad
after a while if i like to come up with
something i was like well no but if it
helps i'm still growing as a person
[ __ ] i got annoyed one girl was like
how much do you weigh she was like whoa
that's body shaming it's hard for me to
lose weight it's even harder for me to
gain height